foreign
[Music]
hey Barbie hi Barbie hi Barbie hi Barbie
hi Barbie hi Barbie
hi Ken
now
I thought I might stay over tonight why
because we're girlfriend boyfriend to do
what
I'm actually not sure
[Music]
okay ladies let's do this
[Applause]
[Music]
here I'm coming with you
did you bring your rollerblades
I literally go nowhere without them
oh looks like this beach was a little
too much Beach for you Ken if I wasn't
severely injured I would beat you off
for right now Ken I'll beat you off with
you any day Ken anyone who wants to beat
him up has to beat me off first I will
beat both of you off at the same time
nobody's gonna beat anyone off
all right